opposers people have wealth like our
president have a lot of lawyers but
sometimes they need a special kind of
lawyer who knows the law but doesn't
necessarily respect it at for Trump
that's Michael Kohn pictured here in his
community theater production of Guys and
Dolls this guy does it all and is under
investigation for most of it what he
sees a problem he knows it needs to be
fixed personal attorney and fixer
Michael Cohen the president's
self-proclaimed fixed on his fixer
political fixer a fixer is a very good
word for him Cohen's a fixer baby he's
the guy who handles all this sexy
off-the-books jobs like hushing porn
stars with a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars of his own money or as they
called in law school please stop asking
how to do that since Cohen is at present
a little legally indisposed I've asked
the opposition's own freelance fixer Tim
bolts to step in and fix all Trump's
wink-wink nudge-nudge problems
congratulations on the new gig
Tim bolts everybody welcome Thank You
Jordan as a freelance fixer I've
identified some problems out there for
Trump and I'm offering my legal services
bro bono I can fix anything
cases dogs oh that's that's the end of
the list okay right so as a fixer you're
also a lawyer according to the Cayman
Islands I am
you got your law degree in the Caymans
no but I had it mailed there it was
actually printed in a town in Malaysia
but at my core Jordan on the detective
like Batman or the dog from scooby-doo
and I smell trouble for Trump in Ohio
then Ohio Trump accuser secures the
Democratic nomination for a seat in the
state legislature
Rachel crooks remember her she claims
Trump kissed her without her consent
when she worked at Trump Tower back in
2005 Rachel crooks what was the last
name I'm a dirty criminal already taken
[Laughter]
problem crooks this human thorn has been
poking Trump's ID with reckless abandon
she held a press conference calling him
a sexual abuser she joined forces with
18 other women to repeatedly smear him
and now she wants to join the state
Senate in Ohio one of America's 50
states yeah so to fix this a normal
lawyer would do something like sue for a
recount
probably but guys like me and Cohen
aren't normal lawyers Jordan we fix
things like fixers do so I'd hit up
every skyline Chile in her district and
bully voters into writing in another
candidate Ohio mega celebrity Drew Carey
great choice the libs would call that
technically election interference that's
a future Tim problem and I hate future
Tim because he knows how Deadpool to
ends and he won't tell me anyway crooks
is hushed problem fix right
so that means Trump's in the clear not
even close because Trump is also under
attack from America's chief brainwashers
teachers when confessed Teacher of the
Year Mandy Manning fake name went to the
White House last week she brought
letters from her immigrant and refugee
students and gave them to trump and wait
until you hear what these letters said
they are thankful that they're here they
have dreams and hopes to be productive
members of our society and that coming
to the United States represented hope
all right lady I see what you're up to
with all these hopeful pleas from
innocent children you're trying to
soften the president's heart and make
him weak like an open border loving
Democrat no way Trump needs to harden
his heart into a crusty blood-filled
rock that he can use to crush Iran and
keep us felt 100
60 pound body and its sexual peak human
right so a normal lawyer would probably
just issue a cease-and-desist that won't
do anything Jordan you got to think like
a lawyer who gets paid in cash this is
how I'd fix it I would write her
pathetic teacher's salary on a piece of
paper then find her car in the parking
lot and stick the paper on her
windshield okay and that that would put
her in her place
I don't know but then I'd feel her gas
tank with concrete she'll never be able
to afford the repair on a teacher's
salary car broken problem fix love it
Buffett rub you are home free no Jordan
I saved the biggest threat for last we
learned two things from the stormy
Daniels situation one mediocre
missionary sex is what all women want
and two Trump hates sharks Donald
Trump's obsessed with sharks terrified
of sharks he was like I donate to all
these charities I would never donate to
any charity that helps sharks
I hope all sharks die stop trying to get
my man to cough up dough for all those
make-a-wish sharks
but don't look now cuz those dolphins
heard about his fear and are headed for
DC this image shows nearly 1,400 basking
sharks gathered off the east coast of
the US
the unusual plankton eating basking
shark has generally been believed to be
a solitary swimmer are you kidding me
this is a swarm of 1,400 jaws --is one
tornado away from becoming a shark he
came all right so what would a normal
lawyer do here would they wait for them
to swim away come on Jordan
I got my law degree from a shitty laser
printer in a town in Malaysia I'm a
fixer I went down to where these sharks
lived and fixed them real good wait uh
you already did something about this oh
yeah a bunch of scientists were like
these sharks are endangered they don't
even have teeth too bad I turned one of
those dinosaur fish into my new shark
skin speedo is that speedo like a
message to other sharks yep and this
thing is horribly uncomfortable plus my
entire apartment smells like a fish
murder yeah problem fix eat your heart
out Michael Cohen my name is Tim dumbass
does tip bolts everyone the fight
continues